welcome back everybody our next guest is
a social media star bringing awareness
to a subject most people find extremely
challenging she is a hospice nurse who
not only brings Comfort to her patients
and their final chapter of life she's
bringing hope and understanding to her 2
million plus followers on Tik Tok check
out what I mean I had this younger
patient like late 40s who was passing of
cancer and she was never married I show
up for a visit one day and she's like I
think I'm going crazy and of course I'm
like why do you think that and she says
this guy I went to college with is
standing at the end of my bed and I said
did he pass she goes I don't think so
last I saw him was our college
graduation I took a job cross the
country and we broke up so I'm intrigued
and I said can we google him so we did
and I found his obituary I'm reading it
and I said doesn't look like he was
married and I got a smile out of her so
I firmly believe they're together now oh
she just put out her first book y'all
it's a New York Times bestseller called
the in between Unforgettable encoun
during life's final moments everybody
please give a warm welcome to nurse
Hadley
[Applause]
[Music]
blos oh my God she walked out and I was
like I own this dress that was amazing I
love this dress it looks so great on you
thank you for being here thank you for
having me this this is crazy Absol oh my
God I love your accent so much okay so
wait do you experience like that video
do you experience like sightings like
that do people experience that often
yeah it's common and when I first got
into hospice and I started seeing it I
was like okay is this a religious thing
is this certain people and I was really
surprised to start talking to my other
co-workers who have been doing it
forever and they're like no it doesn't
matter their background it doesn't
matter how they were raised this happens
to so many different people and it's
very peaceful which is what I love like
people are coming to get them from the
other side and it brings them a lot of
Peace it's beautiful yeah and such a not
you know so great time you know what I'm
saying it's a it's a very hard um
situation so to find beauty in that is
is wonderful it's important for you
right to share this experience with
everybody right it is I didn't expect it
to be so healing um in a way it's hard
whenever you have patients who pass with
regrets um and so whenever I share and
people say oh I'm learning from this or
I am gaining something from this yeah it
makes me feel like my patients are
living on in a way and still teaching
everybody and that's what a beautiful
thing like lessons you're learning as
well like while sitting there and all
their advice yeah what's like one thing
that you love that they've told you like
that you've really taken to heart do you
remember yeah there is one patient who
call Elizabeth and she was much younger
whenever to be on hospice she was in her
40s yeah and I had an eating disorder at
the time that no one knew about and she
had a disease she had lung cancer never
smoked picture of Health don't know why
she had it we still don't know why she
had it she had such a positive outlook
and I remember sitting there one day
just charting and uh she said can I give
you some advice because I see a lot of
myself in you and I said yeah of course
put my computer away and she said I
think I spent too much of my life on the
treadmill said I really wish I would
have spent more time at the beach
without wearing what my stomach looked
like and more time with my friends at
dinners and I really wish I would have
just eaten the cake and she and
physically yeah exactly and she had no
idea how much that meant to me I
actually left and went and ate some cake
that night at a Christmas party yeah
like she told me to eat the cake yeah
yeah yeah so you so the book is now
becoming a TV series which is huge
congratulations on that thank you I'm
excited for it I'm excited for it to
reach more people in different ways yeah
and to kind of talk about something that
people don't really like to talk about
you know what I'm saying because it can
be sad sad for a lot of people and even
like talking with my you know children
about death and grief and all that kind
of stuff because they're young and
they're learning about stuff like that I
like to try and talk about it in a more
positive manner of like well let's worry
about living and not dying like let's
let's worry about this part and it's I
don't know I like that it'll kind of be
in our brains a little bit more too and
that direct impact of the whole
situation and not being so scary for
everybody I think that's so important
whenever you talk about it takes the
fear away and I think that's really
important for a lot of people everything
I wanted to say was just said when you
you take the fear out of it yeah the
weight of it that was you yeah Will said
she writes books uh Hadley's pretty good
at it um Hadley's book is called the in
between Unforgettable encounters during
life's final moments and everyone in the
audience is going home with a
copy Hadley dedicated her life to
looking after people during the final
days of their lives for her it's a
passion and a career but there are
upward of 65 million people across the
country caring for their own loved ones
who are elderly disabled or chronically
ill they don't get paid they don't give
up all you know they have to give up all
their free time they make huge
sacrifices um our next and it's life
altering you know and our next guest
knows that experience well and now she's
stepping up for fellow caregivers by
giving them love and much deserved
pampering so that makes her truly a rad
[Music]
[Applause]
human from caregivers safe place let's
welcome carleta
everybody thank you so in so y'all have
met have y'all met before Hadley right
just now just now oh before backstage
okay they go way back yeah um so what is
your experience as caregiver my
experience of a as a caregiver is uh
it's just like anyone else's you know we
just get thrown into this um situation
situation where you're a caregiver and
you you you know you don't know what
you're going to have to do it's not like
a job where they teach you or treat you
as though you you know you're going to
know what your job description is your
job description is basically to love on
your loved ones um and my mom um she was
my everything so I had to take on that
responsibility of loving her into her
last days yeah woo so Hadley what was it
like to see I mean I'm sure you've seen
caregivers just burn out right what that
has to be hard it's mean physically
emotionally mentally all the way it is
and it's a y'all are the unsung heroes
people don't even realize what what
people are going through every day
trying to care for their loved one it's
extremely difficult thank you yeah
especially if they can't afford care and
it's just like one of those things where
it's like I don't know what I'm doing
yeah like I'm not qualified but you're
thrown into this situation you you you
learn you figure it out really fast yeah
well car you created um help for
caregivers so how did this come about um
I was in my bed after taking care of my
mom and you know with caregiving it
plays a mental role where you think that
you're going crazy you know you don't
realize that you're just you're grieving
from the moment you start taking care of
them to the end so I sat in my bed and I
said you know if I'm feeling this way I
know it's so many other caregivers
around that's feeling the same anxiety
that I feel yeah and sometimes I thought
I was crazy because I would be mad at
her thinking that she was doing it on
purpose and then I would be happy
because she would be happy but then you
know the moment hits that you need to
get it together you have to stay strong
for that person so with me I started the
foundation because I said if I was going
through this I know it had to be someone
else that was going through this that
was not able to get the help that they
needed MH so I started the foundation so
that I could help as many ha caregivers
as I can around the world so that no one
will feel the same Stress and Anxiety
that I felt as a caregiver yeah and just
to talk to someone that's going through
it you know what I'm saying all those
feelings are valid yeah how many people
have you been able to help so far um so
far it's been 35 to 40 people wow um in
which I uh November I gave out um uh
about 17 uh $100 gift cards I just uh
everybody that was submitted to the
website yeah I actually mail those out
um as a surprise for November caregiver
month um and so normally all the other
ones I will randomly if I see you at the
airport and I see you have a loved one
and I feel like you're a family
caregiver I'll give you a $100 GI gift
card or $100 or whichever one um
actually works other others I actually
fly across wherever to Chicago I've gone
to Chicago to Tampa to several several
different places so far
Orlando um and I've given how do you do
that how do you keep that up financially
I do it all out of my pocket as of right
now what yeah I'm a hair stylist so what
I do is I had to stay at work from
morning to night because I needed to
make enough money so I can fly to Tampa
and stay there for a week to surprise
this man that was taking care of his
wife yeah and um so I did that and we
raised $20 and something thousand for
him
wow what that's
amazing you are incredible well we love
what you are doing um and we are not
alone uh Comfort Keepers a leading
inhome care provider for adults and
seniors is dedicated to uplifting the
human Spirit by delivering customized
services to meet the unique needs of
your loved ones to help you give more
caregivers a day off they are donating
$110,000 just to help you
out oh
my than you
much you have such a great
heart and you're doing amazing things
and also this just brings a weird Ness
to people like you never know what
people are going through at home like
what they're having to conquer as well
as their job like yes I won't let y'all
down I promise I'm going to do
everything I can do to make every family
caregiver that I know and that comes
across me that I can help smile at least
one day yeah not for so
overwhel we will be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home